hey welcome back to the monitor I am
Peter Rubin senior editor at Wired and
this week on TV yeah we have mad men but
you know what happens on Mad Men there's
going to be some drinking there's going
to be some carousing there's going to be
some existential crises we've done that
we've been there good show yes but new
show on this week Thursday night on NBC
there's Hannibal no no this is not the
guy across out on elephants this is the
guy who murders people and each followed
beans and drinks Chianti yes Hannibal
Lecter has another media property this
one brought to us by Bryan Fuller who
was the mind behind the television cult
favorite pushing daisies and also left
his imprint on the first only good
season of heroes r.i.p heroes at any
rate Hannibal Lecter the rubric is a
young man psychopath yes he kills people
yes he befriends an FBI investigator who
consults with Hannibal Lecter to help
him solve his toughest cases not knowing
that Hannibal Lecter's also giving
people the whole time behind the scenes
it's very macabre but there's a great
supporting cast Laurence Fishburne is
around Gillian Anderson is back in her
first regular TV role since the x-files
so if that's not reason enough to watch
a new show I don't know what is that's
it Hannibal Thursday night NBC let's
talk about video games have you ever
played splosion man or ms splosion man
if you haven't now is your chance well
not both of them but ms splosion man has
made its way from xbox live with where
it was one of the greatest downloadable
platformers of the current generation to
iOS devices and also Windows PC and also
steam but Twisted Pixel the developers
behind the suitably twisted developers
behind this potion man have teamed up
with another developer iron galaxy to
bring this to the small screen not only
do you get all the glory and
ridiculousness of Miss splosion man on
your phone or on
iPad but they've added a bunch of
in-game challenges and also a bunch of
power-ups there is a ton of
replayability to this it's a lot of fun
and it's like three bucks for a
universal app so how could we go on this
splosion man just hit the App Store late
last week get on now let's talk about
movies shane carruth is a young printer
naturally talented preternatural e
opaque filmmaker in 2004 he made this
time travel movie called primer which a
lot of people just freaked out and
obsessed over and spent hours online
trying to figure out exactly how the
time travel works it was a puzzler he is
back with his first movie in almost ten
years it is called upstream color and
after getting rave reviews at Sundance
and at South by Southwest Film
Festival's it is finally hitting
theaters for a limited run this week I
think it's only starting in New York but
it's going to trickle out to other
theaters thereafter now this is
nominally science fiction because it's
so weird is these two people who who
find that they're kind of part of this
life cycle of this giant I guess it's an
organism it involves this weird plant
and the larvae that live in the plants
roots and also a hypnotist con artist
and also a pig farmer who who records
nature sounds for this ambient record
label if it sounds bizarre it is but
it's breathtaking the sound design is
incredible and it's just really
something to look at and you will feel
lost it's a challenging movie but it's a
great movie it is really small it's
going to be tough to see it but it'll be
on demand soon its upstream color from
shane carruth highly highly recommended
get to see it if you can that is it for
the monitor this week we'll be back next
week with more pop culture goodness but
until then inspirational catchphrase
here
you